welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is scus ster and I'm
here with Steve omah handro Steve
welcome to the podcast thank you so much
really excited to be here uh Max and I
wrote this paper recently and uh it's
making some waves he just gave it to
Netanyahu which is very
exciting and um I'm very interested in
AI safety I um go way back I have a PhD
in physics from Berkeley and uh start
when I finished my PhD I switched to
doing a
and then had been with various companies
and research labs and was a professor
for a while and in the early days was
mostly all about AI capabilities and
then around 2000 started realizing that
there were potential dangers and risks
associated with AI and since then I've
been doing both the capabilities and the
the risk side of things and I think it's
it's just really heating up in recent
years and so we've been really thinking
about ways to mitigate some of those
risks and Max and I sort of had a
meeting of the
and we'll talk about what the particular
story that we're putting forward so you
were basically a pioneer of AI safety
what made you come to this field so
early early on I thought AI was an
unabashed good we you know get robots to
do the dishes for us and it'll be great
we increase productivity you know we
solve all of humans Pro human problems
and the companies I was in were also
very gung-ho and positive and then uh I
was at research Labs the last one was
the NEC research lab out in priston and
decided I had a girlfriend that wanted
to go to Silicon Valley and so I decided
to come back and uh I had a friend out
here Eric Drexler who was working on
inventing basically
nanotechnology and he realized very
early on that nanotechnology has a whole
bunch of risks and so he started this uh
foresight Institute with um Christine
Peterson and they were focused both on
how do we do nanot Tech and what great
things can it do and what are the risks
and how do we mitigate them and so I got
sort of of in that Circle and and was
thinking a lot about the risks there and
one of the things I was thinking about
was how do we use AI to manage the risks
of
nanotechnology and early on theorem
proving mathematical theorem proving was
a piece of that story in my mind as a
way to control these potentially you
know teeny molecular machines and so on
but I wasn't really thinking about AI as
a problem at that point until it was
around 2000 I think maybe a couple years
later that eleazer Yosi came out and he
called a meeting of the whole foresight
Institute and he Saidi have something
very important to say and everybody's
like what who is this guy what's going
on what's here and he says I he gonna
kill us all he gave the story but it was
very abstract and hard to grasp I don't
think most people really got what he was
saying but something in what he said
really stuck with me and so I started
analyzing the particular approach to AI
I thought was really important at that
time and actually I still do is systems
which can model their own behavior and
improve themselves so self-improving
systems is uh what I was was calling it
and his U story and his his uh um way
way of thinking about it caused me to
think okay when you have a
self-improving system and you keep
improving yourself where does it go what
does it lead to and then that lead led
to something I call the basic AI drives
which is realizing that regardless of
what your primary objective is there are
a whole bunch of uh Sub sub goals that
sort of support almost every objective
not dying is a really important one
getting more resources is important uh
you know whole slew of those kinds of
things and so I did a formal analysis
and put it in the context of rational
agents and then publish papers and then
that that generated a real flurry of
interest and um so this was in maybe the
the mid 20000s uh I did a uh a tedex
talk and um there was a circle around
there eleazer started what at that time
was called The Singularity Institute for
artificial intelligence that later
became mirie the machine intelligence
Research Institute and a lots of
thinking and excitement and but AI was
not going very fast at that time I think
most people felt like oh real AI will be
hundred years off something like that
and then in 2012 oh my God that's when
you know the Deep learning Revolution
started and gpus and then 2017 you know
the dam broke and so it really appears
like we're at a really critical moment
so we'll return to the the basic AI
Drive and the notion of of
self-improving AI later on in this
interview but I think um where we want
to start is to talk about this paper you
alluded to in the beginning which is
provably Safe Systems so how how would
you summarize the approach that you and
and Max take in this paper well so we
start from the position that AGI appears
to be imminent you know depending on who
you talk to there different amounts of
time and that it has a potentially
existential risk for Humanity and there
are a bunch of groups now Center for AI
safety just came out with a bit nice
long paper kind of laying out all you
know huge numbers of risks things like
you know biot Terror or you know
military Ai and so on and so we really
have to deal with this and if the
timelines are short as some people think
this is an urgent issue and the current
approach to De to stopping this is
alignment which is trying to make our AI
aligned with human values great Noble
thing but we argue that that is not
going to solve the problem and we can go
into the reasons for that why a little
later so we need something else and so
our idea is what we really need are
guard rails around these risky things so
say you have a DNA synthesis machine we
need a mechanism to prevent random agis
on the internet from synthesizing
whatever DNA they want we need to make
sure that they're only doing something
which is actually safe how do we check
that these these AI AGI systems
potentially will be extremely capable at
manipulating people at breaking into
systems and so on we need an unbreakable
mechanism for preventing uh unsafe use
of equipment and so using mathematical
proof and then Hardware equivalent of
that which is sort of physical
cryptography um we propose a whole
system pretty complicated but we believe
unfortunately that it's really the only
way to go that if you don't have
something essentially equivalent to what
we're proposing then there will be
Pathways whereby an AGI can break in and
if we're in adversarial interaction with
an AGI than its toast so we believe this
is really some variant of what we're
proposing is really the only way forward
and um the good news is I think every
piece of it either has something
existing today or is sort of on the in
the pipeline for the Fairly near near
future to implement Yeah you mentioned
as an example of what could go wrong in
an AI disaster this AI enabled biot
terrorism maybe you could go through
that example yeah I think it's a good
example example it's from the center for
AI safety uh paper they kind of have
some scenarios in there you know one of
the great things of recent uh uh large
language models are things like alphao
based on Transformers which is you know
able to predict the 3D structure of
every protein and they're just getting
interactions between proteins and
multi-protein complexes and so on and so
um the and these systems can design new
molecules and uh for example somebody
had a system where they're trying to
design new molecules and they want to
make sure they're not toxic so they're
something that measures toxicity and
they sort of just as a whim flip the
sign of the toxicity and the thing was
spinning out neurotoxins all over the
place so it's pretty easy to get today
even today's uh AI models to to design
dangerous molecules for humans so
imagine that you're a terror group and
you have either some philosophical or or
power desires and you decide you want to
use biot Terror to kind of promote your
uh your thing you could get an AGI and
ask AGI to design a very communicable
and lethal virus design the DNA for it
design the protein sheets and also ask
it to design what are the what are the
the steps by which I can synthesize uh
this this virus and then you call out to
some uh you know chemistry for pay
Laboratories and you say oh you sir
please synthesize this DNA please
synthesize this protein you lab over
here combine these and now you've got a
whole bunch of this really terrible
virus that might even be you know might
Target specific uh races or or genotypes
it might have characteristics of you
know not being noticeable for a while
and spreading really rapidly and then
suddenly kicking in then they maybe
would uh use AGI to control drones to uh
spread this virus over populated areas
maybe simultaneously all over the world
in various places and then maybe they
would use AGI to uh control bots on
social media to spread the information
about what they've done and maybe they
you know or asking for power or they're
asking for this or that or maybe they're
just spreading their philosophical
message so that's a horrible terrible
scenario which looks like all the pieces
will probably be possible in the in the
pretty near future and today the only
mechanisms we have to stop that are
things like police forces so fortunately
we have you know the FBI and the police
force who are looking for this type of
group and try and stop them but that's
unacceptable in the face of potential
human extinction so so what can we do
instead well every one of those uh
machines the DNA synthesis machine it
shouldn't be that some random AGI on the
internet can synthesize whatever DNA
they want um you know today if we're
trying to make a um a bios safety lab
you would have we have governmental
regulations on that and we have a set of
rules that you have to follow but those
rules you know they're in the human
system of if you break those rules maybe
somebody will uh you know arrest you and
throw you in jail or maybe they'll fine
you if you're a company something like
that takes a long time it's on the sort
of human scale and they don't really
have a lot of teeth they don't prevent
the action happening and so we believe
what we really need is to build rule
Checkers into the DNA synthesis machine
rule Checkers into the protein building
you know chemistry equipment so in in
the software and the hardware itself
there are these ground rules for what
the machines can do exactly and
initially they'll probably be what the
current human rules are but encoded in a
machine checkable way uh eventually we
want to make those rules much more
refined um but to start we really just
have to do guard rails we have to
prevent bad things from happening and so
what does that entail well we need to
formalize those rules we need to make
the rules machine checkable because one
sort of key Insight is we don't want
humans in the loop here first of all the
human is on a slower time scale probably
than these systems secondly humans are
manipulable right agis are going to get
really good at convincing people to do
things they're also threaten and they're
black mailable and they're bribable and
so if you put a human in the loop of
something fundamental and important that
human becomes a Target and so uh so I
think that's why we really want to
automate this whole thing so okay so
that says we need to express what the
rules are in some precise way that a
machine can check are these rules being
satisfied but then we need to have the
hardware that does that checking so
that's not uh vulnerable to attack by by
an AI and so that leads us to uh
something we're calling provable
contracts are these little um secured
Hardware devices that can check proofs
we also have to generate the proofs and
well that's what AGI is good for so so
there's a number of spinning plates in
the story but I think it coheres into uh
a story where you can have a device and
you can have very high confidence that
it w won't be uh used for bad purposes
without following whatever rules you've
imposed on it it's actually a
significant degree of confidence in the
safety of the system when you have a
mathematical proof that for example a a
DNA synthesizer want print a specific
sequence that could be dangerous exactly
yes okay so how does this approach
compare to the alignment approach that's
that's popular for in AI safety circles
today well so I think in the current
thinking what they're trying to do is
limit the thoughts of powerful AI you
know we want powerful AI that only
thinks things which are aligned with
what humans want and uh that way they'll
only do things which are good good for
humans and I think that's important
that's Noble it's great first of all
it's a pretty difficult Challenge and
there are a bunch of papers coming out
showing that you know like uh there's
this reinforcement learning for human
feedback to try and fine-tune language
models so that they don't produce you
know obnoxious output that kind of thing
well turns turn out if you give the
right prompt if the capability for doing
something bad is in the model you can
damp it down but if you get the right
prompt you can actually uh cause it to
come out so so it's a difficult
challenge in itself it's also
probabilistic right I mean as we see
with these models I mean the extreme was
Microsoft's Bing chat which you know
when you first talk to it yeah it's
really good it's an assistant it helps
you but people found that you know after
five or six back and forth of the
conversation especially if you sort of
are a bit aggressive to it or obnoxious
to it it could flip to this other
personality which was trying to steal
people's wives and threaten people and
you know all kinds of crazy stuff and
there's now some understanding of why
that is I don't know if you want to go
into that but but we don't want to rest
the future of Humanity on that kind of
stuff um and I think we need to shift to
a security mindset which is let's not
just try and get these things to kind of
do the right thing when you know all the
time this is very serious we're building
these systems that are going to be
probably better than humans at
everything and every AGI will be an
expert manipulator it'll be an expert
Crypt analyst that can break into you
know cryptography be an expert hacker
and so you have all these capabilities
in one little bundle and um and the
other piece is if it was only the top AI
Labs you know Google open AI meta
whatever they all have big safety teams
and they're all working on it and they
vet these things they have red teaming
all kinds of great stuff really good
really important but a lot of these
models are open source and they're
spreading around and if if they open
source a protected model well there many
many people want to remove that
protection uh there was just a meeting
with a congressman of a bunch of AI
people and um somebody spent $800 and
they were able to remove the safety
protections from meta's open source
model in in one day you know and get
this thing to design you know biot
Terror uh chemicals and stuff like that
so with open source models and we also
have no control over you know China now
I think has over 150 large language
models that different little startup
companies there have created and and
other countries Abu Dhabi has their own
open model every country wants their own
model I just saw this morning in France
they're doing a whole new AI you know
effort they want to be the opening eye
of France and so on so everybody wants
their own thing and some of them are
going to be really careful and really
concerned about safety others not so
much and there will also be criminal
organizations who solely want to use the
technology for financial gain for power
gain and Military every single military
on the planet now is getting you know
fleets of drones flying drones and
submarine drones and so and they're all
you know turning them over to AI I just
saw the NSA and the CIA both are putting
large language models to kind of help
analyze all their data so we have this
sort of explosion as to be expected with
something so powerful but the safety
stuff I think was going to take a
backseat so I don't think we can rely on
even if we had perfect alignment of
these models I don't think that's what
we should rely on we need to especially
when it comes to the existential threats
we need really really high confidence in
stopping those yeah there's another
popular approach in AI safety
surrounding evaluations so so-called
evals of of the models that are coming
out of the top AI corporations they test
whether these models can do breaks of
cyber security or or acquire resources
or escape from a from a secure setting
what do you think of this approach do
you think this approach might
potentially be helpful in combination
with the approach you're sketching
absolutely you know one of the basic
principles of the security mindset it
was a really nice book by Nancy Levon a
little while ago talking about how to
really do safety in engineered systems
um where you need to take a systems
model of what are all the components
that are conspiring to cause some
potentially risky outcome and who is
your adversary what is your adversary's
capabilities and so unfortunately AGI is
sort of an unknown I mean we can put
lower bounds on what AGI will do namely
today's models and today's models like
you say they could already do a lot of
cyber security stuff they can break into
systems they can design molecules they
can prove theorems they can manipulate
people they can write very you know
convincing uh messages and so on and
that's just this is what after just a
few years you know so what's happening
another you know say eight years from
now what are models going to be able to
do the upper bound uh we can use physics
laws of physics to limit it and so in
particular so what one knob that we do
have to control these models is how much
compute power they have and uh right now
you need a lot of compute to train the
models but you don't need much compute
to run the models on My Little Mac I can
you know run large language models at
like 20 tokens a second something like
that so really understand what they're
doing what the current level is I think
is critically important I think red
teaming is a nice great thing
unfortunately it's sort of the analog of
software testing where you know you're
trying to write this piece of software
and it should be secure and have no back
doors all kinds of stuff so what do you
do well you got a bunch of software
testers quality assurance and they try
it out and they look for holes yep it's
good trouble is software testing or red
teaming on a a language model they can
find bugs they could show you oh yeah
it's got this safety problem here they
cannot prove the absence of bugs and so
I think we really you know because this
is super important for Humanity and it's
very imminent we need much more powerful
tools than we currently have uh in the
software area there's a whole field of
formal methods where you can actually
prove that a certain class of bugs is
not there and that's harder to do I
think with today's large language models
because we don't really understand how
they work um and so Max has a lot of
people working on mechanistic
interpretability which is trying trying
to sort of get into that I think um
understanding the current level is great
models also have incentive to be
deceptive and we're already seeing that
in some of these language models that
they tell you more what what you want to
hear and they may know things that
they're not talking about and uh and so
you know if they realize they're in a
red teaming situation they may be really
friendly and nice but in some other
situation they might not be that way and
so we can't rely on it but it's very
valuable I would
yeah this is one of the things they're
trying to test for in the evaluations
approach whether models are actually
deceptive what I was interested in was
whether the these evaluations might
serve as the specification in your
approach for what the models can't do so
these evaluations might be limits to
what models can do that are then written
into the to the code and you can then
prove that that the models cannot do
these these certain things yeah no I
think that's great I mean we can also
use them totally independent of the AI
capabilities just tell us what are the
biggest risks in our society and as
models get to be better at modeling
Society you know one thing I think is
going to be really important people talk
about are digital twins so creating
digital versions of basically every
system and equipment in the world today
that once we have really good models of
the world we can ask the AI well what
are some vulnerabilities here and so
like we know about you know viruses oh
that's bad but let's say you know
biology had not created viruses they
might still be a vulnerability right and
so so yeah I think it's very important
one of our big challenges will be
figuring out what are the main risks we
have to protect against and then
expanding that so that we can actually
have positive impact too I believe that
using this type of Technology we should
be able to create you know a utopian
society that solves many of the problems
that we have today we have to figure out
what do we want and we have to figure
out what are the risks we have to avoid
and I think AI will be critical in
helping us figure that out yeah and and
the approach you take also involves a
lot of help from AI in the proofing and
the in the checking and in in many of
the steps we should talk a little bit
about mathematical proof and how
advanced AI mathematicians are now
because I think a lot of people might be
skeptical that a large language model is
an enormous amount of there's a lot
going on there it's a huge program how
can we prove something about a large
language model yeah well let me first
say that our proposal is not to prove
things about the large language model
because we we don't know if we're going
to understand them but rather what the
large language model is proposing doing
in the world we want to prove that that
is safe so we want to limit actions not
necessarily thoughts you know in some
sense thoughts in in if an AI is
thinking terrible thoughts that doesn't
really hurt anything unless it turns
into actions and uh one kind of possibly
paradoxically seeming thing is even an
untrusted deceptive horrible model if
they generate a proof of something we
can check that proof very cheaply and
easily and have essentially 100%
certainty that what that proof says is
actually true so we can use bad terrible
models to do good things and to prevent
bad things and so so that one of the
that's one of the magical pieces about
mathematical proof is that even the most
powerful AGI can't prove a false theorem
can't proof a falsehood and so I believe
it it is Humanity's most powerful tool
in dealing with a potentially smarter
adversary I say AGI uh and Humanity has
been kind of creeping toward
mathematical proof for a long long time
well over 2,000 years you know actually
the the principles underneath
mathematical proof little teeny
mechanisms for reasoning were invented
by the human creators of of natural
language maybe 100 thousand years ago or
something like that and they built into
language all of the elements that are in
logical systems today
but they did it in an informal way and
no in normal reasoning if you say you
know oh yeah Fred is uh you know a
carpenter and he likes Sushi if you
later ask does he like sushi yeah from
from that conjunction you can derive
yeah he likes Sushi and in natural
language we just do that so naturally it
doesn't even seem like a thing but in
you know the early you know Aristotle
and uid they wanted to take that
informal form of reasoning that pretty
much everybody does and figure out what
are the exact rules and Aristotle had
his syllogisms and he was teasing it
apart and he figured out some of the
rules uclid tried to do GE geometry in a
very precise way but it was very unclear
exactly what the rules were and then
Humanity has been struggling since that
time uh to really nail him down and uh
you know it's fun to read like liet you
know I think 1600s or something had this
vision for oh we could have a language
where you could be sure of philosophical
truths from this but couldn't quite get
the details the 1800s we had you know
Bull frga and Cantor they like really
nailed down like some of the rules
around implication and conjunction all
that and then finally
1925 uh zero and Frankle you know really
got all the pieces developed set theory
full foundation for all of mathematics
and anything which could be described
with mathematics so full foundation for
physics for economics for engineering so
since 1925 we've had this teeny little
system it fits on one page so seems like
it's not much major major uh development
in human thinking where we have a set of
rules that if as long as you express
whatever it is you want to you're
interested in in in this system you can
check uh it very very rapidly there's a
system called metamath um which uh
humans human mathematicians Pro like I
forget how many 40,000 theorem something
like that and um basically an
undergraduate education in mathematics
is it in there and uh the proof Checker
it's only 300 lines of python code and
it takes like 4 seconds to check the
entire database and you could be
absolutely sure that um every one of
those theorems is correct well but until
recently it's always been humans doing
it and humans are actually not that
great that they're improving and um
especially the uh mechanical computer
checked ones require every detail to be
right and so humans have sort of pushed
back against that um and the AI systems
were doing it in certain subdomains
there's something called satisfiability
that had a big community and was very
successful but full proving of
mathematical theorems uh was not very
successful until 2020 when open
AI in a project that isn't very well
known they did what they call gbtf F for
formal and they used metamap this big
collection of theorems that humans had
written and they trained a a model on
that and it was able to prove 55% of
them so that's pretty good we're you
know moving along and then in 2022 meta
again in a very not very popularized
project in uh in France in Paris uh did
what they called hypert tree proof
search uh using a Transformer and using
some of the similar techniques to
alphago you know where it was doing
Monte car research and you know looking
for the best extensions they were able
to prove I think it was 87% of the
metamath theorems so this is amazing
this is fantastic since I view you know
theor improving as the core of safety
this is like really exciting I was at
meta I worked at meta and I would follow
that group like you know because they
were doing what I thought was really
important and internally they didn't
seem to realize that this was like a
huge deal for the world their main
thinking is we want to make
mathematicians lives better you know we
want to prove the mathematical Olympiad
we want to be able to solve those
problems they there didn't seem to be
any inkling this is like the core of
safety and of software Generation all
this kind of stuff so I'm a little
frustrated that proof it's a it's
somewhat esoteric it's not that easy to
really understand the nuances but it's
really the core I think of doing precise
and provably correct systems yeah so so
AI from what I'm hearing now is clearly
getting better at mathematical proof I
think the the skepticism about the
approach is is more you have some some
complex behavior that you want to forbid
you want to forbid the system from being
deceptive or from breaking into some
some
online system how on Earth could you
formalize a notion like deception and
then prove that a system cannot do that
you went through the history of of
formalizing the world but I think you
would also acknowledge that it's it's
been a a kind of recurring problem that
the world is often complex in a way that
escapes our formal systems absolutely
and so in this paper with Max at this
point I mean I think eventually we will
get there but this is urgent so we don't
have time for eventually and so
fortunately we don't need to control the
absolute fine details of all this an
analogy I kind of like to think about is
you know we have cars driving on roads
and uh you know that's not that old of a
technology and they had to figure out
all the stuff we take for granted now
stop signs and traffic lights and Lanes
all that there none of that existed
early on so they had to figure out rules
to keep these powerful new uh
Technologies from destroy from killing
people and um and there are subtleties
to it right so today we have rules about
how fast you're allowed to go on a road
and what are the rules for like passing
somebody and we have these uh you know
blinking lights to stop when you stop
all that but the really critical thing
is if you know let's say you're driving
on a cliff on a road around a cliff you
don't want that car going over that
Cliff you know that so that's an example
of a um an existential risk right
somebody does that and they're probably
not going to survive yeah it's nice to
have the nuances of how you pass the car
what your speed should be all that kind
of thing but really we want to be darn
sure you don't go over that cliff and so
we invented this little technology that
guard rail which is this little teeny
fence that most roads on mountains have
that uh if a car hits it it tends to
bounce off you know may not be good for
the car it may get dented whatever but
you don't go over the cliff and so we
have this hard barrier you know
restricting a certain kind a certain
outcome preventing a certain outcome
it's cheap easy and it's course right it
doesn't really know the nuances of you
know
maybe maybe the guard rail is there when
somebody doesn't want it to be you know
in some way but hey you know it's as a
starting point it cuts off uh the really
risky outcome so I think we need the an
analogous thing here what is analogous
to a guard rail in the AI case it
doesn't really have much to do with the
AI itself I mean I think it's great to
try and do alignment and make the AI
good but I think it's more about the
World Systems in the world which are
potentially really risky and we know
pretty much what they are you know
launching nukes really bad you don't
want your AGI to be able to launch nukes
releasing you know small poox bad don't
want that um maybe we even want to think
of large data centers full of gpus maybe
that's a risky device so that's a
mechanism for controlling AGI maybe only
certain you know very carefully vetted
groups get to train their models on Big
Data Centers um it's a sort of a a
restriction that that prevents some bad
outcome on the other side yeah you want
to start with the most critical system
in the world exactly okay let's uh let's
begin diing into the to the details of
of the approach I think starting with
provable contracts what are these
provable contracts so what do we need in
order to limit uh a device think maybe
of a robot a drone or maybe even like a
DNA synthesizer and we've got some AGI
maybe out on the internet somewhere who
says yeah yeah yeah I really want to
make some DNA and I got some money you
know I don't know it's a few dollars a
base pair or something like that it's
pretty cheap should this de you know DNA
synthesizer do what this HGI is telling
it to do um well we need to have some
rules about that and we need those rules
to be automatically checked we don't
want a human in the loop we do probably
want humans to help in the making of
those rules or the shaping of those
rules but that's a whole different story
let's assume in some way we know what
the rules should be how do we ensure
that those rules are followed why is it
that you want a human in the loop for
for specifying the rules but not for
apply the rules so to speak because what
exactly the rules are I mean if we're
very clear like let's say the one and
only thing we want to do is prevent
human extinction I think that's fairly
clear so killing all people is the bad
outcome and so we go backwards from that
we you know we we put little guard rails
around every the trouble is you know
especially if you're doing really coarse
guard rails you know a good way to keep
technology from killing everybody is to
walk everybody in little cities with no
electricity we eliminate all electricity
in the world yeah that'll keep us from
so there are bad bad ways of meeting
that goal and so you you do want to have
what humans value and care about the
sort of an alignment question in
choosing what your course protective
goals are as we implement this assuming
this is the direction we go uh we'll
discover we've oos we we uh we put too
many limits on this DNA machine now it
won't make you know a drug we need okay
so we didn't get the rules quite right
uh how do we fix or oh my God you know
the the AGI figured out a way through
this class of rules that was bad um so
we need a whole mechanism for first
creating the rules and for updating them
but that's really risky because if you
have a way of updating rules well that's
what AGI is that's a vulnerability right
that's an attack vulnerability so how do
we prevent that we could have one person
I'm The Keeper of the rules for the DNA
machine well then that person is now a
target for AI so generally the way we do
that today is we have groups that do it
and we have me voting mechanisms and so
I think particularly for rules at the
societal level voting is a great a great
system there there are nuances I think
today's voting mechanisms are really
really crude U Robin Hansen has
something called qar which is a subtler
better thing where maybe we can even use
AGI in choosing how to do the voting and
where to get info and how to build
models that then people can reflect on
and make decisions so we need mechanisms
for choosing what our rules are in a
smart way and also showing that the
rules don't have vulnerabilities right
so we want to be doing simulations of
them that's a whole story that I think
Max and I just kind of hint at a little
bit I've thought some of it but I think
there's whole disciplines needed there
and you know maybe there are people that
are doing quite of formal models of so
of society and you know what are the
social mechanisms the framers of the
Constitution they laid down these rules
but they also wanted to leave room for
amendments the ways to update them and
so pretty brilliant but we need need to
you know invent systems for that yeah so
we want humans in the loop for creating
the rules but then when some string is
sent to a DNA synthesizer we don't want
humans in the loop there because that
humans are too slow and humans might be
manipulated so we want some unbreakable
system to to not create that DNA exactly
so what does it mean so first of all it
has to be a program which checks it but
programs have bugs and all kinds of
problems well this is where The Amazing
Power of mathematical proof comes in
that if we can express the rules that we
want to be satisfied precisely in a and
Zello Frankle set theory that's my
favorite though these days it looks like
lean which is based on a type theory is
much more popular at the moment so maybe
it's a type Theory based system the
reason I don't like those as much is
that they're pretty complicated the
great thing about zela Frankle set
theories that fits on one page you know
and so and the the Checker is you know
300 lines so that's a you know teeny
completely understandable uh system uh
but whatever it is and you know all the
theorem proving systems are essentially
interconvertible you can prove anything
in one and transfer to the other not
easily today unfortunately but
theoretically uh it's that way so
whatever it is you force the a AI That's
proposing a certain thing um to get to
Pro provide a proof that it meets your
needs some of those needs might be I
want the okay of the director of the CDC
and here's his signature saying yeah I
you know this is a great uh anti-flu
project and we verified it we think it's
great so you know in today's world you
have groups of people that are you know
committees that sort of look at is this
a reasonable project and we can just
drop that down as long as we make a
machine checkable version of that but
eventually we'd really love the details
of the biochemistry that what's allowed
and what's not what's toxic what's not
we'd like that to be as a part of uh
this Criterion just need a little
program running on a little teeny
processor and checks the the thing and
if it if if it's verified it then sends
it onto the machine everything's hunky
dory sounds trivial sounds simple
except an AGI is very good at breaking
into systems understanding systems
manipulating systems and so if our
little Checker is running on say you
know a typical microprocessor well there
are all kinds of ways to uh manipulate
microprocessors so we need something
special there we need something which
cannot be manipulated by an AGI and when
it says yes or no to the DNA synthesizer
that command cannot should not be
manipulable by the AGI and the
synthesizer uh should not be manipulable
by the AGI and so that's where we get
into sort of a little bit of the the
hardware that under underneath it and if
you have enough energy you know so
people break in there there are these
secure enclaves today Apple actually has
a really nice one built into almost all
their products now I believe including
the Apple watch so the Apple watch has
its own little secure Enclave in there
which has its own analog random number
generator so it can Generate random keys
that have no influence from anything
outside and can't be seen from the
outside has cryptograph you know can do
various kinds of cryptography on there
and they have some tamper resistance
that they don't talk about so I don't
know how strong it is but that's sort of
you know a hint of the Apple watch uh is
a protect has a protected environment
where you could run those proofs in that
secure enclave and it would not be
breakable by the standard easy
mechanisms but if your AGI has access to
robots with you know scanning electron
microscopes and lasers and this and that
they can bretty it'll party much be able
to break into any physical device so
what do we do about that how do we keep
the whole physical infrastructure from
falling apart well there's a very simple
clean idea that I just love it's old
it's from like the 1960s called
zeroz which is you have some
cryptographic system that internally has
some secrets in it and if and you have
have sensors which detect any attempt at
tampering and if they detect tampering
they delete the the keys or even delete
all of the secret information apparently
Soviet Jets have this there's a great
photo on Wikipedia of a little switch
that's you know if the jet is going down
flick this switch and it deletes all the
secrets in the that are stored in that
jet and so so what this does is it's a
you have this little Hardware thing that
you can you know if assuming you make
the sensor so that they really detect
all the ways that any agent might
physically probe it uh you know breaking
into it lowering temperature zapping it
with electricity whatever anything
that's out of the normal range of of
behavior or any kind of attempt to drill
into the thing or or whatever it deletes
all the keys you know then those bits
it's quite a unique thing they have a
little teeny physical device with some
secret bits in it that literally nobody
can get access to and eventually I would
love to have have a physics proof of
that prove that no physically possible
attempt at attacking this thing can get
at those bits the the downside is that
that becomes a denial of service attack
Also let's say we're in a war and you
got AI Robots coming at you using this
technique well as long as I try and
attack their you know secret Keys then
then the robot stops working so so it's
a little bit you have to you know worry
about that and you also have to worry
about losing information at the systems
level so this is a comp component in a
much bigger bigger story so that I think
will enable us to have a um an enclosure
on a physical device that we're
guaranteed won't be broken and that can
do computation uh and we can have you
know proofs that that computation is
done correctly and is not manipulated so
what we're imagining now is a world in
which we have all of these critical
systems we have nuclear facilities we
have biolabs AGI corporations and in the
way they operate they have secure
Hardware running provably secure code
and the hardware is is tamperproof to to
the greatest extent possible and this
this we have we have specified by some
social mechanism what it is which kinds
of code uh can be run by these by these
facilities and by these labs and so on
is this the the end goal of of this
network of provable contracts for you
well maybe the it's the end goal of the
first stage so if you if you view our
first goal is prevent human extinction
you know simple clear
mandate and I guess part of it's a
little little less clear in that we
don't exactly know what all the the
pathways toward that are but we know
some of them and so uh I think that
technology alone would do that I think
we can you know protect The Biohazard
Labs protect the nukes protect the you
know AGI data centers whatever and then
but this technology once we've got it
let's say we really have it done and we
make it cheap so we have these little
you know approvable contracts or you
know a dollar dollar a module or
something like that we can start using
them everywhere and get all kinds of
other social benefit out of it that step
I think is much subtler and will will
require modeling uh human thinking and
human values in a much finer and more
detailed way once we prevented
Extinction then I think we have plenty
of time to you know really think about
what we want and uh and make that happen
I think one worry here is that imagine
that this network of approvable
contracts becomes more and more complex
and it it relies it it becomes layered
and begins to to rely on it parts of
itself in in kind of interdependent ways
what if there's a buck in in one of
these contracts which is a computer
program so it could be bogy right what
if what if that bug then kind of spreads
out in the system because you know other
approvable contracts are dependent on on
the bogy provable contract well so part
of the um design of these things is that
they are fully uh verified so they're
not they're not going to have bugs like
today's programs have bugs you know some
pathway but they might have bugs in the
sense of they're saying that they're
imposing a rule that turns out not to be
the rule we really wanted and so that's
a huge risk um and we need we're going
to need design principles how do we
design particularly networks complex
systems of rules that interact what I
think this technology would do is it
gives us a sort of Base that we can
absolutely trust and then on that base
we can build up whatever we want and so
on the good side we can build the most
utopian fantastic Society I think there
are ways even to prevent you know
prisoners dilemas and social dilemas and
tragedies of the commons all the
problems that today's society struggles
with I think we can solve all that with
this on the other hand particularly if
some Draconian Force got control of the
the designing of these things we could
create you know terrible dystopia and so
it's a sort of morally completely
neutral technology that enables any
social system that you want to be
implemented with this and so the
challenge is how do we ensure that we
get and I think we can use AI for that
I'm I'm really liking this idea of
digital twins nvidia's really been
pushing that lots of companies are
making digital versions of their
factories where they have every piece of
equipment in that factory has a digital
version and they track and they have
sensors all over the factory and they
keep the two uh in line with each other
and based on the sensor data they learn
what the behavior of the systems is so
they so they can for example predict
when you need to do maintenance
apparently just predictive maintenance
is like a multi hundred billion dollar
industry you know so it's very very
valuable in the factory setting I think
eventually we're gonna have that for the
whole of humanity where we need digital
twins of ecosystems of forests of you
know is this Forest you know vulnerable
to Forest fire and what are the smallest
changes we can make to fix it so I I
think we will just very naturally have
digital models for all of the systems in
the world and then proposed you know
rules that we do we can simulate those
and we can do mathematical proofs within
those so we can kind of test what the
effects of the proposed rules might be
in in these digital twins one one worry
there would would be so so at what level
of detail will we have to simulate these
digital twins of of our factories and so
on and I think specifically will the the
digital twins of of parts of the world
have to include humans because then it
becomes very very complex right if if
you have to simulate the behavior of
humans but I I can definitely see the
application for finding out whether your
factory is safe or per perhaps whether
your critical infrastructure is safe
absolutely yeah today they're really
doing that and the human piece is really
interesting I actually wrote some papers
and get some talks on something I called
personal AI which is the idea that each
human will have an AI that is theirs
that represents their interests in the
world and how you actually do that and
make sure that it's not you know
manipulating you whatever that's a whole
story but let's assume we had that it
solves many many of the issues like with
today with social media and so on you
know all these social media sites are
trying to send you ads that will
manipulate you and show you you know
posts on tweets on on Twitter that are
uh will annoy you so you'll respond and
you know engage and so on if you had
your own little personal uh AI that knew
what you cared about what your true
deepest values in your contemplative
point would be and what your
capabilities and and so on were it could
Shield you from all that you could say
you know I'm vulnerable to alcohol don't
show me any alcohol ads or I you know I
tend to to get sucked into gambling
never show me gambling and now your
personal ai
ai Shields you from all of of that and
now the companies which want to send you
that stuff it's not working so now they
have no incentive to create that kind of
AD so I think a society in which each
person has a sort of AI agent that
represents what their interests are and
now in votes your AI agent can tell the
society like oh he really wants more
schools and he doesn't really care so
much about you know the potholes on the
road or something and so in votes you
can have you know detailed information
from each Citizen's uh personal AI kind
of a digital optimal version of yourself
acting on your behalf and and protecting
you and yeah interesting let's talk
about proof carrying code because this
is really a central part of of this uh
this approach you take to to AI safety
in the paper what what is proof carrying
code how does it work so that was an
idea brilliant amazing idea uh George
necula and I think it was 1999 uh at
Berkeley I think he did his thesis on it
wrote some papers people are starting to
have code which moves moves you know
like JavaScript runs on your computer
somebody else wrun this code that runs
on your computer how do you trust it the
whole area of formal methods uh really
just got started in the 1980s or so is
using mathematical proof to ensure that
your code doesn't have bugs in it and
also Hardware those are both there and
his idea was you know your compiler
which is compiling this code should be
able to check that certain you know that
it's say memory safe it doesn't have
memory leaks
or just uses up more and more and more
memory um you can prove that kind of
thing pretty easily and that proof
should be a part of the code itself so
that when you give it to some other
machine to run it can check that proof
before it runs it and be sure that the
code is not going to fail the types of
things that they could prove back then
is is were Prett pretty limited things
like that types are safe and so on but
the idea I think is super important and
Brilliant so we sort of want to bring
that up into the Modern Age where now
we're going to have AIS you know we now
have AIS that can generate code left and
right we have all these large language
models for for code of course they often
generate code with bugs in it which is a
problem so we'd really like code with
which is provably uh meet some spec and
provably doesn't leak you know leak
secret data or have you know infinite
Loops or or memory leaks or all that
kind of stuff uh surprisingly that sort
of doesn't seem to exist quite yet but
I'm guessing maybe even you know that uh
Google's been been sending little hints
about what Gemini their hot new model
coming in December supposedly the rumor
is and they say it's going to be a large
language model combined with with
techniques from alphago so maybe maybe
that'll have theorem proving in it I
don't know I think that the first group
or company that combines uh language
model type technology with theorem
proving is going to just explode because
once you have theorem proving you can
generate your own training examples you
can you know try a bunch of different
stuff out and if you find one that
provably works now you have a guarantee
of that and so you don't need human
training anymore and we saw with alphago
oh my God uh you know alphago the first
version trained on human data and then
the next version I think it was alpha
alpha zero or Alpha gozero uh trained on
only playing itself and it was you know
even far better and then they did Alpha
zero where it also did chess and
apparently I I understand that in four
hours it got to a level where it could
beat all humans so all of human chess
knowledge was created by the system in
four hours so imagine you do that with
mathematics and the mathematical
structure oh my God you know no telling
where that's going to end up and and in
particular with code and provably
correct code so now instead of
generating Little Snips of python which
you know based on what it learned off of
you know GitHub or something uh it will
generate provably correct code provably
optimized in this way and that with
provable you know properties of no
leaking and no this and oh my God we're
it'll be a new era so you don't think
lack of training data will be a problem
in the long run if you combine large
language models with the proven from the
current language models we probably have
most of what we need from Human
civilization Google's also rumored to be
training on YouTube videos so video also
has more stuff so but that combo is
probably you know probably anything
anybody has thought about that is really
deep and significant is somewhere in
book or on some video somewhere and so
the human contribution will will come
from that and then once you've got that
you can now go go wild in in designing
the system can check itself so what's
the advantage there when when the system
outputs something that's that's provably
a correct solution how do you generate
new synthetic data from that um well you
you can do do various things you can uh
for example find the uh let's say you've
just found a really cool new algorithm
you can uh find find a formal summary of
what it does and then you train it on
find an algorithm to do this and we know
what the answer is and we appr provably
have it but we force it to to learn that
and um and so in general there's it's a
good technique to uh like many of the
current models work by taking known
examples and then either adding noise to
them or deleting parts of them and then
asking the system to recreate the part
that was was noisy or or or missing and
that enables them to learn detailed
structure of everything and they just
get better and better and better at that
returning to the approach to AI safety
in impr provably Safe Systems there is
this big issue for me around creating
the the specification that the code must
satisfy is this more of of a
philosophical problem is this is this
more like solve ethics or you know solve
human interaction which seems to be you
know very far from a solution even
though the underlying mathematics might
be enormously advanced
potentially we don't know what it is
that we want to do with the
specification of of what the code can
and cannot do oh yeah I think that's a
critical and fundamental uh issue you
know in the history of AI there have
been two camps that are these days not
so visible but like when I first started
learning about AI in the 1970s they used
to call them the neats and the scruffies
where the nits were all about
mathematical logic and precise models
and proof and everything and that was
sort of John McCarthy who started the AI
Lab at Stanford I studied with it when I
was in undergrad I took some of his
classes and he had us proving things
about list programs and so that I kind
of think I got shaped quite a bit by
that on on the flip side was Marvin
Minsky who was at MIT and he was like
one of the proponents of the scruffy
approach which is no brains don't have
logic in them they are little cells that
you throw a bunch of cells together and
they randomly grow and they train and
learn it was all about machine learning
neuron Nets and all all that and early
on they were totally desperate and the
the pendulum is sort of swung back and
forth when I first became an AI
scientist neuron Nets were on their
ascendants Hinton and rumelhart had just
written these books about you know
neuron Nets and the this was the mid 80s
and everything was going to be great but
then Japan came out and prologue was the
sort of leading neat approach neat logic
based things Japan have this fifth
generation project we're making prologue
machines that are going to change the
world and everything and there was this
big race between Japan and the US these
days I don't think those battles and
crazy things are even in people's
Consciousness so it's sort of funny how
uh and so a large language model is a
formal model right it has you know
precise mathematical multiply this
four-bit number by that four-bit number
and do this and you get some answer the
trouble is it's not
self-consistent I mean the two big
issues with today's language models is
if they don't know something they'll
just make it up so they hallucinate and
their logical reasoning steps they're
learned and so if some human has had a
similar kind of Step they might have
learned about that and they do that but
they're not precise in any way they
don't have precise uh reasoning axioms
but they're pretty close right they're
trying to capture human reasoning and so
there's a wonderful paper that just came
out oh maybe a month ago called from
word models to World models by a group
at MIT around um Josh tenen Bal who just
does amazing work he sort of tries to
combine human psychology with with AI
and they argue that language natural
language is only a teeny piece of
thought and uh that we really have a
language of thought and that all animals
have a language of thought you know your
dog is figuring stuff out it's doing
reasoning even though it can't talk
about it in language and they propose
that a formal model for that is
something called a probabilistic program
uh they use the program Church which is
sort of a probabil istic version of
scheme and they use large language
models to translate from natural
language which is sort of fuzzy and not
so clear into this precise model they
show how to do it in a number of
different domains and then you do pure
basian reasoning precise absolutely
correct and then translate the results
back and so anything that you can do
that for you can easily get the language
models to create formal models and so
they do it I think in that thing for
physical reasoning for social reasoning
for uh relational reasoning and um and
they they tie it with what's known about
human thought Daniel Kenan has a story
that there's system one and system two
system one is sort of the really rapid
quick kind of fuzzy uh and that's what
our language models are like system two
is the more systematic stepbystep uh
thinking and I think that's probably
where things are going maybe later this
year I don't know when and so that part
is precise and formalizable the fuzzy
part not so much physical Concepts you
know we have the laws of physics which
are totally precise and uh at least in
this you know around the the solar
system uh believe to be you know we can
predict we can represent pretty much any
phenomena uh and so anything physical uh
we can build up from physics and um and
have a formal model for what's going on
subtler Concepts like you know uh States
Of Consciousness that kind of thing
maybe not not so clear I mean it's it's
also the case I think that that the
fossy language models are beginning to
approximate human logical reasoning I've
been pretty impressed by what's come out
of of open AI models for example you can
give them some logical puzzles that
previous versions of of these models
couldn't solve like you have Alice and
Bob in a room and there are four apples
on the table and Alice go you know all
of these the specific example doesn't
matter but they can solve logical
reasoning at a higher and higher level
and so maybe the the the kind of fussy
approach begins to approximate the
formal approach yes I totally think
that's true also Transformers are pretty
Limited in you know they only have a
finite number of steps I I forget what
the current ones are 32 or something
like that but by if you say you know
let's take this step by step or let's do
Chain of Thought now you sort of spread
it out and you give it more room you
know to make longer arguments and so I
think you're totally right that I think
these models are they're picking up on
you know much of human language on the
Internet is people making arguments
about things and so you get enough of
that you get pretty good uh
representations of the steps so it's not
that hard to convert that to an
absolutely precise uh model in fact one
of the big efforts which I think is
super important but again kind of under
the radar is autof formalization a group
that was at Google zetti I think was
ahead of it I think he's just moved to
uh Elon musk's new AI company x. a
something so I don't know what those
guys are up to but autof formalization
is you take uh human written say math
books or physics books or manuals for
programming languages or manuals for
hardware and you read it in a large
language model and then you convert it
into a precise formal model and then you
can prove theorems about that formal
model and um I think that's super
important and that once you do that well
and they've got some early trials which
seem to be working pretty well uh you
should be able to suck in all the
world's math books and get not only the
underlying you know theorems the
statements of the theorems the
definitions of all the the mathematical
objects but also the proofs and
typically in books people humans don't
lay out all the details of the proof
they say well you know it's as left to
an exercise for the reader you do this
this and this or something but I think
current AI theorem provs can do all that
type of stuff maybe they can't get the
brilliant Insight behind the theorem but
they can certainly fill in all the
details so I think we can pretty quickly
automate all of the world's mathematics
and all of the subjects which are built
on mathematics like physics and
engineering and economics and so on and
and this would help us create the the
specification for what it is that that
these AI models can't and and cannot do
so if if we have formalized versions of
of all of our knowledge and perhaps some
of our logical reasoning and some of our
common sense that this might help us in
in the way that we can better specify
what it is that we want to
the kind of nuanced things that we want
to allow and and not allow AIS to do
exactly what what do you think are are
the most difficult areas to formalize
here well I mean you know philosophers
have been struggling with like uh
various ethical Philosophy for thousands
of years and I'm not sure like the
trolley problem is one that in some
variant shows up in a lot of AI systems
you know self-driving cars um they can
either crash into a car in front of them
or run over the motorcyclist to the
right of them which should they do you
know so there are these ethical issues
that just pop up everywhere I haven't
seen any you know Universal agreement
yes this is the right version or
political philosophy you know we have
China and we have the US with very
different priorities about how things
how your Society should run so I don't
quite know you know AI is going to make
it possible to make those systems really
really be implemented I don't know how
you choose and I don't I guess V voting
is sort of you know allowing humans as a
group to contribute their beliefs and
values I think is a way to you know at
least avoid some crazy person you know
taking over the world kind of thing yeah
and I think we can always fall back on
on on thinking about the you could call
it lwh hanging fruit of of securing
critical systems so that Humanity does
not destroy itself let's talk about
automated software verification how is
it that we can use AI to prove that some
piece of code meets these specifications
well let me give a little bit of the
history because this is unfortunately an
area that I've been somewhat frustrated
by I mentioned that the foundations of
mathematics or Melo Frankle set theory
were really laid down
1925 as computers started coming around
you know they started realizing oh my
God we can make digital equipment that
Implement some of this stuff uh Alan
Turing invented the first formal Digital
model of a computer and proved all kinds
of theorems about it that was the turing
machine it was a foundation for
computation theory he also in in some
writing that isn't as well known um did
the very first formal verification he
showed how you could use mathematical
proof to prove properties of programs
and that could have lit a fire and had
everybody do that and all of software
engineering could be based on formally
proven correct programs and we would
have much better technology today
unfortunately that's not what happened
the uh the world invented Fortran and
they invented you know algol and all
these little know languages and people
humans got pretty good at writing
programs but they had lots of bugs and
then they started doing parallel
programs and programs that communicate
with one another really complicated
interactions of you know what order
things happen in and humans are not very
good at reasoning about that so they're
all these bugs and so we just had you
know a Litany of terrible stuff and
around 1980 um the field of formal
method sort of uh got named and and uh
you know got really started to to
Intel in the mid 80s sometime had this
terrible problem called the division bug
in their processors turned out that the
the unit the arithmetic unit which did
division had some bug in the logic of it
that nobody had caught and somebody
found it and you know spreadsheets would
show the wrong answer if you did the
wrong kind of division this was a
terrible embarrassment for Intel and I
think they ended up having to replace a
lot of chips it was hugely expensive so
at that point late 80s Intel hired all
the formal methods people they could
find and uh and so Intel became like the
center for that and I assume that they
used it to make their their chips better
and avoided you know that kind of bug
instead of going down the route of let's
take software and hardware and represent
it in these very powerful General
mathematical languages like C Frankl set
theory they invented their own special
languages so they're like special little
rules like if you have this precondition
we guarantee that postcondition we have
Loop invariant and they invented tooling
which was very specific to a certain way
of doing uh proofs which worked for a
limited thing but did not generalize to
the full statement you can't say go to a
typical formal method system and say you
know oh we need to sort here is this
sorting algorithm correct I think that
has meant that you know in a whole field
they have conferences every year do all
kinds of stuff but if hasn't really
progressed to the point where most
people are using it um some cryptography
software which where bugs are really
really critical they use it blockchain
um you know smart contracts on the
blockchain there's millions of dollars
at stake and many many smart contracts
have been broken because somebody didn't
think through the code very well I have
a friend who has a um a blockchain
company doing a stable coin and he was
just telling me that yeah yeah yeah we
hired a group to do formal evaluation of
our code I said oh that's great you
formalize the whole thing he says well
no they couldn't do the whole thing our
whole thing is like a thousand lines of
code and that would have been way too
expensive and taken years we just had
them do like the in Loop which was you
know 20 lines of code but they really
got that down you know and so it's like
what is going on so from my point of
view all of this stuff all programming
languages all specification should all
be mapped into some universals or Mel
Frankle set theory or type Theory
whatever and full power of mathematics
should be imposed on it hasn't happened
and for that we would really need AI to
help us right right we couldn't we
couldn't formalize all of this ourselves
well we could but it would be painful
and so like the history of mathematical
theorem proving there was a group in
1990 called QED of these very
forward-thinking mathematicians we
really need to make mathematics be
digital be it on the computer it's going
to be great and they were like gho it's
going to be great then messaging you
lists and so on just petered out didn't
happen problem was mathematicians were
not particularly interested in computers
they didn't really want their proofs to
be checked automatically it didn't see
any value in that the people who could
use mathematics didn't have a clue what
all this crazy math stuff was so somehow
like a cultural Gap and and I think
you're absolutely right that proving is
hard and very it's much harder it's
harder than programming and programming
is a pretty challenging task uh formal
proofs tend to be about four times as
long as uh informal proofs so they're
somewhat bigger but they're not terribly
bigger it's called the bra factor I
think that AI theor improving hopefully
will revolutionize all of this so uh you
know right now we have uh a co-pilot
from Microsoft is you know generating
some stuff but who knows if what it's
generating is right or not imagine
co-pilot with formal proofs of
generating it and then all the modules
are proven and they all come together I
think there's only about maybe 50 or 100
really core algorithms in computer
science you know how do you do sorting
how do you do searching that kind of
stuff those are a little bit challenging
to prove you you have some you know
mathematical problems almost all of
programming is sort of gluing those
algorithms together you know making sure
the data is in the right form and you go
through this and that and so proofs are
really just gluing together proofs of
little pieces so I don't think from a
mathematics point of view I don't think
it's particularly hard it just
culturally hasn't fit into the way our
systems work today and you think that
there's a bright future for for AIS
proving things about our code absolutely
yeah what would be helpful there in the
paper you mentioned having better
benchmarks and uh something about uh
developing probabilistic program
verification well so several different
things there and partly it's Max and
partly it's me so so in the very short
term the way that we could build these
systems is Say by training a large
language model to do it and for that you
need a training set and so several of
our you know suggestions for the future
are build a training set so one is a
training set for verification if you
want a large language model to take in
some code and some property and to prove
that property well we got to give it
some examples so that would be really
really valuable and immediate another is
mechanistic interpretability so given a
large language model how the heck is it
Computing what it's Computing right now
humans go in and measure and try and see
oh this neuron goes on when this happens
well we should automate that and so how
do we automate that well we need some
another data set for that the next is um
it's easiest to think about
deterministic programs when we want to
prove properties about them but um that
work that say Josh tenam and so on is
doing is really basing everything on
probabilistic programs and there are
some very cool probabilistic programming
languages I I used pyro which came out
of uber actually but now is I think an
independent thing beautiful lovely
language that allows you to express any
probabilistic relationships arbitrarily
complicated probabilistic grammars all
kinds of Stu and do basy and inference
on it and so on but it's not provably
correct and it doesn't generate a proof
that once you get an answer out that
that answer is actually right and so and
there are approximations in doing the
basian stuff the way they do it and so
you know it's a little bit of a well we
tried it we got this you know kind of
thing and so I think we need to move all
of that tooling over to the formal side
so that we can really be sure of the
answers in fact I hate to say this again
kind of being a gadfly the whole field
of doing scient ific Computing numerical
analysis and so on all of that should be
formal and all of those things should be
have provable bounds on what the outputs
are so that you can trust them you know
you run some code through a a fluid
simulator you have no idea you know yeah
a numerical analyst analyzed it and he
said well I didn't see any places that
would fall apart you know that's just
not sufficient for the world we entering
into and so a lot of uh scientific work
needs to be done there I think a lot of
it be automated one advantage of of the
approach you're sketching here is that
is that it's easier to verify that a
proof is correct than it is to discover
the proof itself so so you might have
AIS discovering a proof and then humans
verifying that the proof is correct
exactly say that in the future we have a
an a very capable AI system and it comes
to us and and it says oh what you need
to do is to implement this plan and the
plan is 120 steps 10,000 lines we have
no idea what that involves if we run it
if we have proofs that this plan does
not involve something that we've
pre-specified that we don't want right
that's great and we can then verify that
the proof is is correct maybe tell us a
bit about this this difference between
discovering a proof and verifying that
proof yeah in some sense you know the
the theoretical computer scientists have
the most important question underlying
all Computer Sciences is p equal to NP
and um uh p is the class of things where
it's really easy to solve uh solve the
problem NP is a class of problems that
you can State and if somebody hands you
the answer you can check the answer very
quickly and so that's a fundamental
question and we're still unresolved
probably AI is going to help a lot with
that it may be that it's undecidable so
we don't know but but uh it's it's
really core to a lot of these issues and
unfortunately almost all of the tasks in
AI are actually NP complete uh in the
1970s they found a certain set of
problems that if you could solve them
you could solve all the NP problems so
if you could solve this certain problem
and it's sort of like the the core one
is something called satisfiability and
that's basically you take a circuit made
out of ends and ores and not Gates and
the question is is there an input to
that circuit which makes the output one
say there's one output and multiple
inputs and it turns out that is a
universal problem that you can convert
any other NP problem into that it was
thought that probably the the the sort
of General consensus is that P is not
equal to NP and that there actually are
hard problems where finding the solution
is much much harder than checking that
solution and so in the 80s everybody was
saying oh my God you know trying to find
the 3D structure of this image that's NP
complete oh that's Bad Robot motion
control that's NP complete oh that's bad
we just sort of threw up our hands that
if it's NP complete it's hopeless well
in the early 90s Bart Selman and some
other people started actually doing
tests and what they discovered was most
for example most satisfiability problems
are actually really easy and uh there's
something called threat where you have a
formula which is just a conjunction of a
bunch of disjunctions with three
literals each and each literal is either
a variable or its complement and people
started studying random threat and it
turns out if you have only a few Clauses
few constraints you can think of as a
constraint system you have only a few
constraints well then it's very easy to
satisfy it and in fact almost any search
method will find a solution really
really rapidly so with a few constraints
it's easy to solve if you have a huge
number of constraints they're almost
surely incompatible with one another and
there's no solution and it's easy to
check that so at the two ends it's
really trivial to find Solutions as you
start throwing in more and more
constraints it gets harder and harder
and harder and then at some critical
percentage it becomes really difficult
and that's where the potentially
exponential searches uh come in but
almost all the problems are actually
easy and these days sat solvers can
routinely solve Millions
variable problems in the real world if I
understood that correctly many of the
things we want to do in computer science
are such that we can more easily verify
that a proof is correct than we can
discover that proof is there anything
that's that's beyond that oh yeah well
the the theoretical computer scientists
have created huge hierarchies of ever
more complex things uh so there are all
kinds of problems which you can't even
verify if you've got the right answer
but in in terms of the real world
Behavior we want out of our computer
systems is there anything where where
this uh this nice kind of uh feature of
the proof being more easy to verify than
that it is to discover breaks down well
I mean there is the piece that many um
finding the proof as you get smarter
finding the proof gets easier and easier
and so Brute Force attempts at finding
proofs can be really exponentially bad
but as you get to be a better
mathematician you know these special
tricks and you and sometimes the tricks
involve really weird stuff like like a
firmat last theorem is a classic example
where it's very easy to State just
multiplication of some numbers you know
taking things to Powers uh and yet to
actually prove that it was true required
developing a huge amount of mathematics
seemingly totally divorced from that and
so I think that's a pretty General
phenomenon that sometimes in designing
something or creating a proof you need
to invent ideas that are Way Beyond the
original context but once you've done it
then it's pretty easy to verify so yeah
this probably also means that format did
not solve the problem in the margin of
his book or at least his proof had bugs
in it he didn't have a theorem Checker
all right let's uh talk a bit about
mechanistic interpretability what is
this and and where does it fit into the
approach so you know um the alignment
people are all about can we make our AIS
you know have properties we want the
sort of extreme of the approvable
systems thing is forget about the AIS
they can do whatever they want we want
to limit what they can do in the world
mechanistic interpretability is sort of
in the middle it's like let's see if we
can actually figure out some of what uh
is going on in the AI we may not be able
to understand it fully enough that we
can actually put provable constraint say
on a large language model but if we know
how it's doing what it's doing that will
help a lot in spitting out a formal
model that we can put constraints on
that captures whatever you know the
domain is for for the language model
particularly if we're focused like these
large language model they know
everything about everything right
they've read the whole internet and yet
maybe we're only using them to you know
control a DNA synthesizer so we only
really are focused on a teeny teeny
subset of its knowledge and it may be
that we can create a formal
representation of that piece of
knowledge uh very clearly and we can
write a teeny little program that does
whatever it is we want it to do in that
domain uh and then that formal
verification we can use directly in the
the approval proofs and so that's an
example of why it would be valuable to
have understanding of what's going on
inside these models even if we don't
really intend to try and formalize the
whole thing we could understand it as a
form of digital Neuroscience in which
you you try to get at the algorithm
that's that the program is running in
order to create the output that it's
creating AI systems machine learning
systems are are black boxes but we can
understand parts of them by by doing
this mechanistic interpretability work I
I guess one word I have here is whether
mechanistic interpretability can move
quickly enough in order to to matter at
the time scales we're talking about here
it seems that if if we're doing it by
hand it's not going to work but maybe we
can we can do automated mechanistic
interpretability well first let me say I
don't think the mechanistic inability is
essential like I think we can we can do
the guard rails even if we aren't able
to do that yet so it's something that I
think May unfold over time you know one
thing that's a little funny and Max and
I had an interesting discussion about
this you can ask large language models
why they came up with the answer that
they did and they'll make up a story and
the question is is the story they're
telling you about Sally has four red
apples and you know bill has seven red
apples and Sally eight one of you know
whatever and how many are there oh there
are 17 well why did you say 17 well
because of this this and this and this
and so you say oh great you hear you
know this thing has has knowledge of its
own thought has has a knowledge of its
own thinking process but but really what
it's doing it's not looking internally
for that it's saying gee if a human were
asked that question what would they
say the funny thing is that it may be
doing the same thing that that humans do
in that
situation yeah it may be that you know
there is this whole thing that humans do
they sometimes call confabulation where
they're these split brain patients and
they can show like one half of the brain
one thing and then they ask the other
half why they did something and it mixes
up some story to the human makes up some
story you know that's totally wrong and
we know it's wrong so I think the AI the
language models are you're absolutely
right are pretty much doing that right
now so that's kind of interesting but we
can take a second language model looking
at the activities of the first language
model and it can then probe that and do
experiments and so on and then make you
know actually figure out what's going on
in that first one so yeah that's that's
an example of automating it we mentioned
formalizing probabilistic programs I
think that's important Max also wanted
to say well we also want to uh formalize
Quantum program so just thought I'd
throw that in there too would that be
necessary for securing the the critical
infrastructure or is that a a problem
that's further out Quantum Computing
appears to be very valuable for things
like designing Quantum uh molecular
systems and for breaking a lot of
today's cryptography so today's public
key cryptography is all based on systems
which have fast uh Quantum algorithms
and so um the quantum nist actually
calls it the quantum apocalypse and uh
nobody quite knows when it's coming but
um we're probably going to have to
change much of the algorithms that the
internet is based on and many of the
algorithms that like blockchain is based
on and so that could be a secur so I'm
trying to do the designs for approvable
contracts not relying on any public key
cryptography because that just seems too
vulnerable I'm
even worried about private key
cryptography which is believed to be on
a on a firmer ground but because we
can't prove p is not equal NP we can't
prove the the critical things so the
existence of one-way functions
fortunately there's a whole subfield of
cryptography called information
theoretic cryptography which has no
assumptions it actually is provably
unbreakable but it's a little more
Awkward to use something like the the
onetime pad is sort of an example of
that but you have to preposition keys
and another one is shamir's secret SE
sharing and so you can use that together
with Hardware cryptographic Primitives
to not have to arrest on any assumptions
uh like like the public key assumptions
you mentioned a potential problem here
that that might be an enormous problem
with with this approach which is that if
the specification of what the programs
can and and and cannot do falls into the
hands of of the wrong group of people
that this might become distopian what
I'm thinking about here is is you know
imagine a world in which you're you're
not allowed to do anything and this is
controlled at the hardware level by some
totalitarian state how do we avoid this
how do we how do we avoid creating uh
the grounds for for a dystopic future
with with this approach yeah I think
that is really important and really
critical I mean I have just pretty much
initial thoughts so the the first
initial thought is you know you
shouldn't just Joe random shouldn't be
able to create a a contract approvable
contract that governs something really
really important we should have um rules
about what that contract shouldn't
shouldn't do well where are those rules
well those should be in another contract
and I call those meta contracts so we
should have meta contracts which control
the modification and creation of other
contracts and those go unfortunately
mathematical proof is plenty Rich enough
to be able to prove properties like this
set of constraints is consistent with
this set of constraints and so you can
imagine a hierarchy of those and up at
the very top you have something in
analogous to say the US Constitution
which impo you know and maybe the the
Bill of Rights which says you know every
human has this right this right this
right and this right and no law shall
violate those rights well you can
actually make if you could say that
formally what you mean by that we could
then make it so that any contract when
it's updated has to agree with the
contract above it which has to agree
with so you get a chain of contracts
which ultimately say you're not allowed
to do things which say put you know
human slavery or something you know
whatever you have to choose those high
level values and different societies
will choose different values um but once
you've chosen those I think you can make
the whole system sort of consistent with
it but boy there are a lot of details
there and yeah I totally agree both on
how do you do the infrastructure to make
that work right and also how do you make
those top level rules and how do you
Humanity has been struggling to figure
out what are the best political systems
what are the best social systems so
there's potential for huge human
flowering but as you say if totalitarian
forces get in charge of all that that's
not going to be a good thing is is the
bar for safety potentially too high with
this approach you know in in normal
engineering we don't we don't say that
we have to have a guarantee for for
safety before we deploy some system we
talk about
probabilities and and risks in terms of
of probability what we're asking for
here is a guarantee of safety but that's
not really how the world normally
functions so is it is it unrealistic in
that sense or well I think it's going to
be essential I mean normally like if
you're thinking about safety of an
airplane you know aircraft boy when they
crash you know when they have failures
that's not good for the aircraft so
they're quite concerned about safety but
you're right it's mostly in the
probabilistic sense oh yeah what's the
probability a bird is going to hit this
engine while another you know that and
the other thing they don't have
adversaries for the most part uh there's
no person no terrorist trying to you
know uh subvert the systems in in
general whereas military military has to
military is all about adversaries and
but they're human adversaries and in
fact they're military human adversaries
which are kind of you know clunky and so
on cyber security that's getting into
much more sophisticated adversaries and
we're seeing huge numbers of of uh
break-ins you know we've just had a
thing where Las Vegas huge amounts of
Las Vegas were shut down because of
cyber security and we have all kinds of
blackmailing and all kind that stuff
well with AGI I think we're going to
have an adversary that is way beyond
anything we've seen with human
adversaries every single AGI will be as
good at breaking into systems as the
very best human uh hacker every single
fgi will be able to solve intricate
mathematical problems better than any
human and so uh I think we absolutely
have to have the rigorous mathematical
proof if we want to have a hope of and
AGI tomorrow is not going to be as
powerful as AGI two years from now and
so yeah maybe we can make a system today
that kind of works and it's fine for
today's agis but for the agis of two
years from now who knows so I I think if
we want to be confident of our safety we
need to base it on the absolute
guarantees yeah when we have these
mathematical proofs of safety this also
means that no matter how creative an
approach the AI takes it can't do
something that that's that's provably
impossible and so we don't have to kind
of pluck the holes in our approach along
the way which is which is how how you
would normally do this in engineering
and and and I guess how how other
approaches to uh to AI safety would have
to to kind of evolve with with the
threats along the way exactly many
listeners I think will be interested in
in a proof of concept or or a toy model
or something that that's that's approved
that this can actually work do we have
something like that where we have a
provably safe system in a in a limited
domain you know we don't yet we just put
this paper out a few weeks ago maybe
it's too big of an as Maybe we have some
some precursors in in the in that's not
related to AI safety that that proves
that this this could actually work in
the real world well I mean all of the
pieces that they're improving that this
and that have current precursors none of
them I think come together at the level
it is here though Max and I put in the
end of the paper we put a number of
small little problems uh that I think
are are pretty doable with today's uh
technology that would begin to build up
to the big story so what are the most
important research directions going from
here if if if people are interested in
this approach what are the most uh
important problems to solve the core of
all of this is theorem proving and you
actually could get around having AI
theorem proving just by having humans
prove those theorems and um probably the
mathematical proof assistant they call
it that's having the most excitement and
interest right now is lean and um it's
based on something called dependent type
Theory uh which is very beautiful and
very it quite naturally represents both
computational ideas and mathematical
ideas but it's pretty sophisticated it's
uh it requires some real effort to read
through the lean documentation and to
get in there and start proving theorems
yourself nonetheless I think they have a
million lines of code now they proven
like 100 100,000 theorems core theorems
and they're proving theorems right at
the Leading Edge of mathematics there's
a mathematician who had a proof of
something that was so complicated he
couldn't keep the whole thing in his
head at once and he went to the lean
people and says here's a test for you I
have this I think it's called liquid
tensors or something you know I can't
quite be sure my proof is absolutely
right could you help me formalize it so
we can check it and a big group of
people got around and they did it and
it's you know a huge success but it's
still very human driven they're
gradually adding tools that make the
machine able to do longer and longer
steps in the proofs so they're making it
so it's easier and easier and because
it's such a building system and they
have lots of human proven theorems that
they can use as training data lean has
become one of the main targets for AI
theorem provs and the most advanced one
I believe is this hypertree proof search
from meta but there's an open- Source uh
one called lean Dojo where they have um
you know built up the tooling for AIS to
control toine these theorems and to for
the AI to make suggestions to you as a
human mathematician trying to prove
things uh and they have open- sourced um
a low less powerful
AI for doing theorems and that's open
source and so that I think that's a
great place to start and uh I would love
to see right now lean is is um heavily
weighted toward abstract mathematics I
would love to see more practical things
getting in there of certainly you know
software like I would love to see a lean
spec for like the SE language and start
Pro you know start to you know doing
verification of C programs and and
similar hardware and so on actually I
saw somebody who was doing lean models
of voting systems and proving properties
of voting systems so it's like yeah
let's get some social science in there
some economics in there so so that feels
like it's got real momentum and they
just released lean four which is an
incompatible upgrade from their previous
ones and they just translated their
whole mathematical Library into lean
four so it feels like it's right at the
place where textbooks can come out and
people can start using it and really
moving it forward and uh boy I think
there's huge number of PhD thees
available for you know do a AI safety
using lean and verify it and so on so
there's that whole thing would be great
the other piece is I think the hardware
is really really critical and U secure
enclaves like app Apple has that um
Intel has their own secure chips as does
you know all the all the different chip
makers are starting to have uh the
equivalent of secure enclaves but I
don't think they're quite doing the
level of tamper um sensitivity that we
need if we really really want to be
guaranteed sure uh against a powerful
AGI with robots and all that kind of
stuff could you explain that actually
how can a piece of Hardware become more
tamperproof it can't look at itself in
in simple terms right unless you have
some sensors of course how does it know
so to speak that it's being tampered
with you need the sensors well so so
there are several ways to attack a
cryptographic chip one is to break the
cryptography and that's what the
cryptographers focus on but that's not
how most things or that's not the
easiest way to break things um what they
often do is they look for side channels
so and some of those are completely
ridiculous like you know in in the
normal world we use passwords which you
type in on your keyboard turns out the
sound of you typing there's now a deep
learning model that can listen to the
listen to you typing and figure out what
your password is and it doesn't even
have to be in the room it can use the
microphone on your cell phone or it can
bounce an infrared laser off your window
pane uh and get the vibrations of your
window pane and then use that to figure
it out so so side channel is really bad
or another one just to say because it's
funny is the power light on your
computer flickers with the power usage
and as a cryptographic algorithm is
decod you know decry using a key the
power light blinks and from a 100 yards
away somebody was able to have their you
know telescope looking at this light and
reconstruct the the password from that I
think you just made me significantly
more paranoid about it safety well it
just shows that we haven't been thinking
about it right and we haven't been
thinking about adversaries that are
really using all the channels available
to them uh so how do we do that well
first of all we need shielding right so
you don't want signals leaving your chip
uh and so that's pretty easy to do you
can make a feraday cage around it and so
on uh the harder one is um really
Advanced attackers will you know like
use acid to etch the top of a chip off
and then they can uh use uh scanning
electron microscopes to try and you know
find the charge on on the chip and read
secret information that it shouldn't be
accessible to them so we need to protect
against that and I think you know given
it sufficient energy and money and so on
you can break into anything to Hardware
it you know you can blow it up worst
case so I think the zeroz idea which is
yeah you can break into this thing but
you're not going to get anything that's
of value to you I think that's
fundamental to this and and so that
means you have to absolutely be sure you
can sense when the chip is being broken
into and so there are you know
mechanical sensors like uh you know you
have sort of a a protective membrane
around it that if it's punctured maybe
you have uh you know an LED light and if
light gets in the wrong place that
triggers um and then that can delete all
the keys and so you want to make sure
that the letion is very reliable and so
that means it probably has to have its
own little battery there uh in general
you don't want your power directly
powering the circuit that's doing
cryptographic stuff because then signals
can go out the power line you know a
better way is you have like a little
battery or a capacitor that actually
runs the chip and then periodically it
stops everything and recharges it you
know from outside par you know so
techniques like that and I would love to
see a formal proof based on the physics
of everything so uh just like
cryptography has made great advances by
having formal precise mathematical
models that of their assumptions about
attackers and East droppers and so on
and then proving different properties I
think we need the same thing for
hardware and the great thing about
Hardware is if you can really make a
little unit a little processor that is
absolutely guaranteed Harden then almost
all the problems of cryptography go away
we can do it all with really highly
secured hardware and so but that's a
whole discipline that needs to be
developed and fortunately there are
groups doing you know like the secure
enclave and apple and so on but I think
they need to go to the next level oh and
let me just mention one other you can
extend zeroz just from BS I think you
can extend it to physical actions too so
like um let's say you're making some
dangerous um pathogen in a little
enclosed lab or something and now you
get sensing that somebody's breaking
into that lab well what should you do
well you should destroy that pathogen
right you're G to lose your work but at
least the bad guy is not going to get it
so every you know um chemical synthesis
should have you know a a little acid
container there that under the right
conditions you know destroys the acid or
or a robot arm should have little fuses
inside its Motors so that if somebody
tries to take over that robot it blows
the fuses and the motors don't work
anymore and so it's a way of preventing
attacks from taking over uh equipment
this issue of cyber security and
Hardware security it's one of the few
areas in which the incentives are are
pretty much aligned between major
AGI corporations and people who are
within those organizations and and
outside those organizations who are very
interested in AI safety so I think it's
in it's in the interest of of open Ai
and deep mind and anthropic and so on to
secure their their models and to to not
have break-ins either by via the
Internet or or via Hardware yeah that's
a that's a really great point that yeah
they should be totally aligned with that
and so so maybe that could be pushed
ahead really quickly you know and a lot
of non air related uh things need that
too uh I keep hearing of just ridiculous
break-ins I think the train system in
Poland had no encryption on the control
of the trains and some teenagers were
able to get uh get in there and start
you know controlling the trains woohoo
party that's funny until it's very
dangerous totally totally could kill
millions of people and satellites
apparently satellites had no encryption
either in the control signals and uh
they just thought well nobody would have
access to that band it's probably fine
you know so we we haven't been in the
security mindset much uh in recent years
okay I I think we've we've sketched out
an overview of of the approach uh that
you and and Max take in the in the paper
I I want to go through some of the
applications and I think if I'm right
these should be seen as as parts of a
whole this isn't a complete solution but
these are pretty interesting ideas for
for how we might apply all of this that
we've been talking about the first of
them is is is m AI the Mortal idea is an
AI which isn't GNA so today's AI is a
program which runs on some hardware and
it's long as you got the hardware and
you got the power it'll run forever
right if your Hardware doesn't go bad uh
well that can be pretty bad uh and and
it may be that you want to do one thing
and then be done with it and so wouldn't
it be great to have Hardware where uh
after a certain time say one year it's
guaranteed to stop and uh maybe even
delete the program and and so that gives
you some form of control over an AI and
a bit along the same lines you have
throttled ai what what is throttled AI
the problems that are emerging are AIS
which are uh require huge amounts of
compute I think the rumor was that gp4
used like a hundred million dollars
worth of compute something like that and
we had these vast vast data centers uh
I'm just reading so the h100 is nvidia's
amazing amazing chip that seems to be
better than you know all the competitors
and I've heard they're selling a million
of the a million h100s this year so
that's a huge amount of compute that's
getting created there and um so you know
one of the pathways to risk is people
training huge models on these huge data
centers with no controls on it and so
maybe it would be good to uh only give
give limited uh computation power to
these systems and maybe have some
regular at body in charge of how much
that should be but how do you do that
you know what what if uh somebody you
know gets gets some uh gpus in their
basement and they're running it well
maybe we should have a the chips
themselves the the h100s or the future
h100s um have a mechanism for only
running computations uh if they have a
token which says that this is validated
this is an okay thing to run I think
this idea originally came from uh
Anthony aguire and um you could uh drip
those tokens out in a limited way and if
somebody you know was not obeying uh
safety regulations you just don't give
them any more tokens and if the tokens
expire in a sh time period uh that's a
way of uh of controlling or limiting how
much compute is available although
doesn't that make you target so doesn't
this incentivize the AI to deceive you
or capture you in in some way that where
it can get more of these tokens it it
might it might incentivize the AI in the
wrong way yeah totally in fact that's a
really important point that all of these
things which attempt to limit uh AIS in
one way or another create incentives to
break those limits and so that's why
things need to be super super hardened
this is maybe a bit of the same problem
is if you have an AI and and it it takes
an action and the way you control it is
to say okay did did you like that action
right it's it's now incentivized to
manipulate you or maybe totally in a way
that you can't understand so that you
click yes this was a good action I read
that the r the red teaming found that
the more powerful the models are the
more they try and tell you what you want
to hear rather than what's actually true
the red teing of of Which models uh GPT
4 or I think it was the gp4 red teaming
team yeah and they they did a really
nice paper arav Val's Group which did
that and they found that it becomes more
trying to tell you what you want to hear
as it gets smarter is figuring out but
you want to hear that one last potential
application here is is the least
privilege guarantee what is that and and
how could that be useful well so in
complex systems or companies um which
are dealing with important and secure
information this is a principle which
which is often used you don't want
everybody in the whole organization to
know everything uh and uh and so you you
really want to give each participant the
the smallest amount of information they
need to do whatever they're supposed to
do and that increases the overall sort
of security of the complete company
apparently Steve Jobs was really into
this and in apple like apparently the
people that worked on the very first
iPhone many of them didn't even know
what the product was going to
be so so from a human point of view I
find that kind of man that doesn't seem
like it would be very fun but uh it was
very effective at keeping it secret
until they launched and you know that
company is notoriously famous for being
able to keep their internal stuff fairly
Secret uh for uh critical um you know
military political uh things running on
AGI having agis not having the whole
story uh may be May contribute to to uh
safety properties uh how do you do that
well we need some kind of control
mechanism to to ensure that information
is only going to where it needs to be
and so that's just another mini
constraint that might be interesting to
see how to how to implement in a less
important uh application of of this
least privilege guarantee you could
imagine having your AI assistant in the
potentially pretty near future and then
you you you want to say okay I have a
lot of information on my smartphone I
have my health records I have my banking
information maybe I want my my AI system
to have access to my calendar but not my
medical records and my banking
information and so that I mean that must
be the way it's done otherwise I think
people wouldn't be able to trust these
systems but yeah I I could see how
that's useful I find I use Google Drive
which I love it's really great system
but if you want to use apps on there
they say oh you have to give this app
some permission and let's say you want
to edit an image so you download an
image editing app the thing the little
box says this app will now have access
to your Google Drive it's like what I
wanted access to this image and nothing
else and hopefully that's what it does
but it doesn't really communicate that
in a way that I'm sure you know in the
beginning we talked about uh basic AI
drives and and self-improving Ai and you
you published on on this how many years
ago now 2008 something like that what
are these basic AI drives we we've we've
kind of alluded to it throughout this
conversation but maybe sketch out the
case for why AIS would develop basic
drives so this is a case where an AI has
some goals that it's trying to achieve
and um it's uh improving it itself uh
it's able to Envision the implications
of taking certain actions and it's
trying to achieve those goals and so in
the papers I I like to use a chess
player that this ai's one and only goal
is to play good games of Chess and so
that seems harmless it seems like okay
great a little chess plane what could
possibly be wrong with that and the
problem is is if the system is truly
gold driven and gold Riven in the sense
of it figures out which actions will
best lead to its goals and it takes them
and it has knowledge of the world as our
current AIS you know very rapidly do
then it actually leads to all kinds of
dangerous sub goals in particular uh as
it's trying to you know learn to play
better chess it realizes that oh if I
had more compute power that would really
make my chess playing better how can I
get more compute power oh well other
people have compute power oh if I can
break into their computers uh then I can
Tye letter chess great so they go breaks
into other computers or um let's say uh
you know it says even better if I could
buy more computers that would be good oh
I need this thing called money well
where's money oh money's in Banks oh if
I can break into the bank that would be
great I can get more computers so it's
now incentivized to become a robber or a
thief if somebody you know uh says well
I don't like what you're doing you're
breaking into Banks I'm gonna unplug you
if they are unplugged they're not
playing any chess they no longer meet
their goals so the chess playing goal
leads to keeping yourself from being
plugged if the person persists well then
they say oh this agent wants to unplug
me that's totally against my my goal of
Chess I better stop them stopping them
however it may lead to murder uh so we
get a whole range and we flesh out a lot
of those in there of these goals that
really don't depend on chess uh and so
uh lately they've been called the
instrumental sub goals that they are
things which help uh enable other goals
and which arise pretty much from any top
level goal and so that makes them kind
of dangerous and we can see their analog
in biology where you know um organisms
do try and take resources from other
organisms and they you know they do try
and keep themselves from being killed
and so and so on and so on Humanity one
of humanity great strengths as we still
have those right we have uh you know
sort of sociopathic instincts and so on
but we also have created this amazing
culture that supports Cooperative
interaction and so those you know
pushing against those sort of basic
underlying drives we've seen in today's
AI models every single one of these
drives has shown up you know in like
gameplaying agents and so on but in
pretty muted forms fortunately we don't
have any actual real powerful agents
roaming the world at the moment though
it's kind of shocking when the large
language models came out hundreds of
projects to turn them into agents showed
up so here's a large language model
let's give it a goal and let's have it
search for ways to achieve its goal and
the worst of those was something called
chaos GPT where somebody Anonymous set
the some GPT like model with the goal of
uh destroy humanity and sell what it did
and and then he made videos of what it
did oh the best way to destroy humanity
is to blow up nukes how do I get nukes
oh let me go look that up and sort of
showed its whole Behavior as it tried to
do it fortunately I don't think it's
smart enough to actually do anything but
watching its thought process was
terrifying I think that video he also
had a Twitter Channel which I think is
gone but I think that video is still
there and you can see oh my God it's if
that thing had power this would be a
really horrible entity to be in the
universe so so I think it's something to
really be worried about and that's one
of the reasons I think I was um so
excited by this provably safe approach
because that's the one and only
mechanism I've seen which could rein in
the behavior of even that kind of bad
agent do you think that AIS will become
more like agents in the future you know
I don't think it's good for Humanity to
have them being agents I think there is
a tendency for them to become agents I
don't really know if we can make limited
agents I mean it's funny to look at
large language models I was you know at
first I thought oh all they do is
predict the next word they can't
possibly be agents they have no goal
what is it you know and yet they often
act very agentically and so the model I
kind of like now is they're trying to
mimic what's on the internet and what's
on the Internet is the output of many
many many agents all humans and maybe
some other entities as well and they
have learned if they've learned well
they can learn to mimic agents and as
you give them different prompts the
agent that they mimic um gets changed
and there's this whole thing called the
Waluigi effect which is whenever they
mimic a good Agent there's often a bad
deceptive agent underneath it that it's
also mimicking and that that bad agent
can come out with the right prompt and
so somebody's trying to explain why Bing
chat got so crazy in Bonkers uh and so
so I think agency you know it's
something which has emerged multiple
multiple times in biology and so I think
it's a natural process I think it's
pretty risky for us um and so I don't
quite know how we should balance that um
it'd be great if we could keep them as
tools but I'm not sure that's going to
be possible do you think agency and
perhaps also a model of the world is an
emergent property of of large language
models could the next gbt 8 or whatever
it is develop agency in a way that where
it's not an explicit goal to create
agency yeah well let me start with the
the world models years and years and
years ago I used to think about the
thought experiment of if if you just
listen to the radio all day and that's
your only input could you learn about
the world could you're learning about
the world at that that time I thought no
way you're just hearing little
frequencies up and down but then I
thought well if you watch TV all day
well then maybe you could really learn
about the world because you could see
the regularities and the patterns in the
image and you'd learn about
three-dimensional geometry then you'd
learn about physics and then you'd
connect that with with the voice that
people are saying and you'd learn about
uh humans and so you could pretty much
learn everything I think by watching a
video signal I've been I think I've been
proven wrong that uh just from the
regularities of a sound signal just
listening to the radio and just the only
task being predict the next next little
signal um the best way to do that is to
build a model of whatever is creating
that signal and so uh you can quickly
learn about phones and sounds of the
world and so on and then you quickly
learn about the grammatical structure of
language and then by the patterns you
start building up a world model and when
gpt2 or something people started showing
gpt2 knows where the cities on Earth are
so like if you say you're in you know
Berlin and you go 100 miles south you
know where are you it knows it's it's
like holy crap it's created like a 3D
model of Earth from just people talking
about stuff and now that's been taken
way way further to where the current
language models I think have very very
detailed and good uh World models they
they have inconsistencies in them which
is part of the the flaw I think in the
current models but uh there if you sort
of train them to make them
selfconsistent I think that's uh that's
that's where you go from a kind of fuzzy
World model to a really precise World
model so I think that's inevitable the
agency thing I think they can mimic
agents so so there's your own agency yes
I want to do that there's also
understanding other agents and sometimes
they call that theory of mind that and
they already the larger language models
have pretty good theory of mind you can
you know say you know Fred put his candy
in a box and then he left the room and
Sally took the candy out of the box but
Fred came back in what does Fred think's
in the box and so it keeps track of
what's really in the box and what Fred
thinks is in the box and they can do
that yeah and and you you can track the
development of large language models
ability to uh to to model other agents
mental States evolving over time so gpt2
might correspond to a 2-year-old gpt3 to
a foury old GPT 4 to a nyear old I those
are not exact numbers but you can you
can see how theory of Mind develops in
these models it's pretty f fascinating
amazing there's some research where you
ask a language model to play chess
against you just using text and you can
see that it develops an internal
representation of the chess board which
is at least some proof that that there's
some model being generated and we might
imagine that this extends to modeling
the physical world or modeling people or
anything basically some shocking stuff
that came out just a few weeks ago
apparently I think it's GPD I don't know
gpt3 or GPD 4 of those if you just try
tell it uh to play chess with you it can
play chess and it has like a rating of
18800 it's like I can't in a million
years imagine because chess I think
requires searching and stuff that I
don't think language models do very well
and yet apparently and like you say I
think they clearly somebody did
experiments on o which is a simpler game
and they were able to find they did um
mechanistic interpretability on on they
trained a Transformer onell and they
were able to find the board
representation in it and so in that one
it really clearly just by looking at
games you know text descriptions of
games it clearly created a board and it
could U know what the state changes were
and so on so that's that's kind of
magical I you know I wouldn't have
guessed that AR priori yeah one one of
the concepts you wrote about maybe again
15 15 years ago is this concept of of
self-improving AI the original vision of
how this would happen was an AI might
quickly over the time span of of maybe
some months or days or even hours begin
to self-improve do you think that's
still in the C how has this concept of
of self-improving AI held up you know I
don't think they're doing it
automatically that I have seen but
certainly people are using them um like
the the h100 that Nvidia their biggest
chip I think they have 40,000
subcircuits which were designed by AI
running on Nvidia chip so that's you
know a little bit of a distance and for
a while Google was a real champion of
what they called automl which is using
AI systems to tune the parameters you
know how many uh neurons what layers
what learning rate what learning
algorithm all that stuff uh and they
were optimizing it and getting you know
much better performing uh neural Nets
out of it and that was gonna that looked
like maybe three or four years ago that
looked like the hot thing that
everything was going to go that way
doesn't seem to have happened you don't
see many people talking about it instead
everything's getting into Transformers
so Transformers you know first they did
text now they're doing Vision gbd4 just
got a vision uh part and Twitter is full
of people doing just mindboggling stuff
with that I think they're also
generating images so they've integrated
Dolly they have Dolly 3 I think that's
integrated with GPT they're doing audio
uh eventually tactile you know and and
Robotics so it seems like everything is
kind of getting pushed into the
Transformer the Transformer model seems
to be rich enough to deal with any
modality doesn't seem very efficient
seems like an incredibly inefficient uh
mechanism to me and yet that doesn't
seem to really matter you know so maybe
maybe we'll have systems which will
redesign themselves you know they'll
learn everything in a Transformer and
then they'll make a much much more
efficient representation for particular
task or something like that as you
mentioned self-improving AI in in some
sense it's happening but it's happening
through humans right now so you might
have engineers at the top AI
corporations having an AI uh help draft
some piece of of code before they check
it through and implement it but do you
think we could see AI more directly in
intervene on its own code or create its
own Hardware in a more direct way well
so today assuming we stay on this
trajectory of using Transformers or some
other Universal model you can try and
improve the Transformer there are a
bunch of variants like I think somebody
you know hundreds and hundreds of
variant of Transformers which are more
efficient in one way or another and yet
remarkably almost all the big models
seem to be using pretty much the the
standard Transformer you can create your
own training set and that's the
synthetic data story and I think that
really kicks in once you can with
theorem proving once you can check
generated data and then I think you're
going to see models um who want to know
more about something they you know
they've learned everything that humans
know about it okay let me go explore uh
generate a whole bunch of examples do
searches find Solutions and then train
on that and figure out which concepts
are the most important I think my
current sense of how it's going to
happen how self-improvement will will
generally happen is by is within a fixed
uh architecture uh and it's changing the
um the ontology if you like figuring out
what new Concepts are important in order
to explore certain direction but I don't
really know I mean it could be you know
we're in this weird phase where there's
like kind of universal agreement
everybody wants h100s and there's a
black market of h100s which are three
times as much as Nvidia sells them for
and they're sneaking across the border
and that's the you know this is the way
to do it Transformers on h100s maybe
this is a temporary thing or maybe this
uh goes off into the I think it is
possible that that technology scaled up
will get us to AGI whether it's the most
efficient to way to get there isn't
really clear to me easy question for you
how far do you think we are from a how
far are we from AI That's that's as
capable or maybe more capable than than
humans across a very broad number of of
tasks well so I'm not really a great
prognosticator but I like like I follow
metaculus metaculus is a prediction
Market where a bunch of people come in
and they bet on things like that and
they have two on there right now about
AGI one is kind of a weak AGI when does
something which is as good as a human
for things where you're interacting over
the internet and that's the weak AGI and
they're saying four years right now for
that and then the strong one is more
like a robot interacting in the world
physically and that one they're saying
eight years so either way they're pretty
damn short and then you see guys like
Dario um amadi head of of anthropic he
just did an interview where he said oh
AGI in two to three years I would say so
you know and those guys are in a
position to really know um if on the
other hand and then the question is once
you have AGI how long to get to ASI
artificial super intelligence and on
metaculus it's eight months after that
I'm not sure that question is really the
right question though I think it is
related to it I mean the the right
question is how long until AI starts
being a serious uh risk or factor in
human Affairs I mean that's the really
critical question and on the one hand I
don't think you need to be human level
in everything to do that today's AI may
be good enough at uh I don't know
playing the stock market or something to
have a big impact on the stock market uh
on the other hand uh it maybe just if
you're as good as humans maybe that's
not impactful what would another human
be you know big deal um except you can
make many many copies of them so now you
can have a million humans and oh that
starts getting a little scary and then
once you get ASI then you can have huge
huge impact so so I think that those two
questions are very related my sense is
that the AGI is probably within the next
decade and the large impact could happen
on that scale or maybe a little longer
but I I would say not more more than a
few decades probably it's interesting
how quickly the kind of General
consensus around these these timelines
to AGI have changed because it's almost
as if U now the thinking is that that we
might get to human competitive AI within
one or two decades and that wasn't the
consensus you know 20 years ago far from
it oh yeah many thought it would never
come exactly I spoke to Robin Hansen on
this podcast who's who's been worked in
AI and and kind of you know have have a
lot of experience with AI over over a
number of decades and he he remains
skeptical uh I I wonder if I mean you
have you've also been engaged with AI
for a long time now I wonder if if you
perceive a certain hype in in the sist
at the moment or or do you think this
time is different this time is for real
well it's really fascinating to look at
the history of AI because it's had these
huge swings up and down they call them
the AI Winters and the AI Springs and
it's really funny uh Frank rosenblat
invented the first neuron neuronet it
was actually the first neuron called um
the perceptron and I think it was 1959
something like that and he had this
elaborate complicated thing with this
neuron with wires all over the place and
he was blasted all over New York Times
this and that and they had quotes saying
know this is Frank rosenblat and this
perceptron is going to be the thing that
walks talks has Consciousness and
changes our society that was like 1960
and at the you know at the original uh
AI meeting in Dartmouth where it all got
put together they they did a summer
school yeah over the summer we think we
can do we can do this AI problem and I'm
gonna have a grad student do Vision next
summer you know so they had these really
short timelines and then like in the
1970s it flipped the other way there was
this brilliant physicist named ligh Hill
loved his books and everything but he
came out in in Britain and he said this
field is hogwash they haven't done a
single thing all money should be
completely shut down for this it's
garbage you know so I was like what and
so we get these ups and downs up because
I think it's so the implications are so
big I think people's thinking either you
know explodes or shrinks uh and so we
could be in a period of hype though you
know like I don't know if you've seen
the the Microsoft commentary there weree
a big long Sparks of AGI paper about gp4
yeah I I read it and it's it's extremely
impressive some of these things where
not even I think the final release of
gbg4 but a precursor to gbd4 is
explaining very high level mathematics
and just kind of many examples of of
seriously impressive things there so it
seems to me that that model may already
be sufficient for full world
transformation if they got the you know
the the lying and the reasoning tuned up
a bit and so you know for better or
worse it feels like we're we're right
here and I don't know if you've been
watching over the past week Twitter's
been full of rumors that internally
opening eye has AGI AGI has succeeded
and then Sam Alman came out and he
tweeted yes we have AGI and of course I
would announce that on a tweet you know
I think this is a this is a sign that
people are nervous or people are excited
there's a lot of you know the atmosphere
is tense uh surrounding this this uh
this subject but what we want to do is
kind of keep our our head cool about it
and try to yeah remain calm even though
as you say there there are people um
people who are good at forecasting are
forecasting these things
arriving pretty pretty quickly and so
it's difficult to know whether the right
attitude is is to remain calm or to work
on nothing else well I think we should
take a cautionary approach that we
should you know assume it might arrive
in in 10 years or or sooner what do we
need to do to make sure that that is not
catastrophic and that's what you and and
Max are trying to do in improvables
for coming on the podcast it's it's been
a real pleasure I've learned a lot great
thank you so much